okay everyone uh welcome to the meeting
of the cabinet north east alberta
district council it's the 21st of july
at 4 30.
we've got a single item
agenda today
um on the uk shared prosperity fund
investment plan um i'll go through the
the the normal business so we've started
with apologies i think we've got
apologies from cancer parking for any of
us allen and i'm receiving
okay
uh any decorations of interest
no okay
and then we move on to the the main item
uh the
uk shared prosperity fund investment
plan so hand over to steve lee
as our assistant director who's gonna
talk
from the investment plan over the last
few weeks
does that matter yeah sorry
for the last few weeks
and
we've gone out to consultation with a
range of farmers
okay
based on the
initial discussions we've had on um this
council and our our partners feel that
we can meet the objective of building
the priming place increasing life
chances across northeast ocean districts
and the purpose of this paper is to
receive endorsements from cabinet and
also the approval of the finding that
the finance final investment plan
submission is dedicated to the director
of finance and resources in section 1.1
we're still working on the financial
figures so
we've not got those for you today but
that's because we're trying to get an
almost plan that's deliverable within
quite a short time scale
in terms of the finances
[Music]
so
in terms of managing finances we've been
we've got
just over two and a half million pounds
to to allocate and
the the risk is that possibly manageable
within the existing council's financial
regulations
uh we're also looking to establish a
fixed term post which is paid for fully
through the funds to act as a program
officer
with other
staff from across the council to deliver
so for example the constitution under
the party priorities
so the background's covered with um
about two and a half years to allocate
uh the funding when we receive it and we
expect to find out in october this year
that they've been approved
and then we're going to start spending
straight away so although it's a
three-year program technically it's two
and a half years
and um
we are looking wherever possible to link
the strategy with our
existing council plan and the priorities
that we've got not within that
so the consultation that we've
undertaken has been
quite widespread we've had
some
one-to-one meetings with two mps
districts we've had a focus group in
this room where we had
various partners around the table to
feed them in their views we have a
survey that was sent to over 100
stakeholders which included every
district council of parish councils and
revenge of the sector representatives
the business sector
community sector
organisations et cetera
so
we feel that we've had a good breadth of
reaching out and a good range of
comments that come back which helps us
to try and shape the plan
while it's balanced is very focused on
the visual prize that we want to
engender and divide further
within the district
as you can see in 2.4 we've got 11
things which um
which we've put together to to try and
shape shape that approach
and um most of
the priorities that some of the
communities in place of the the patient
spiritual fund
do recognize the need for supporting
local businesses
providing advice and guidance and
physical regeneration to the high street
we also recognise that we want to be at
the forefront of skills development
in the area so we're looking to
develop energy to assemble that energy
skills focused on trade so people can
look skill and we've got a ready enabled
workforce to take advantage of the
forefront development climate change
mitigation in the future
so the budget is an appendix ii which
has been identified
that will be
taken into the appendices for the
investment plan which our partners have
made to consultancy and they're working
on at the moment
but the
plan itself as i say because the time
scales that were involved we are
suggesting that the the final assignment
goes to section one five and officer in
consultation with the leader and uh the
managing director it is recommended that
that is the process
by the
developer as part of the patient
government approach and we are looking
at um
ensuring that
we're looking back to the support of the
stakeholder orders of weakness
previously
so moving on to the recommendations
and
we've got the suggestion the industrial
investment plan to ensure the timeline
submission and then to ensure that we
can keep it up to speed with the most
appropriate
applications of funding that we
delegated as discussed
so hopefully to take any questions
if there's anything in particular
okay thanks very much steve um
the priorities in there reflect um
absolutely council priorities um you
know things like riding the public realm
and improving parts and play areas and
some of those tourism sort of
improvements like the support of
chesterfield canal for example there's a
huge range in there certainly very
visible improvements to the district as
well which i think most of our
communities can see
sort of firsthand which i think is
really important there's there'll be a
million different
2.5 million different ways to spend this
this fund but actually i think we focus
here on the really important visible
things that people will notice when
they're looking around the districts and
see firsthand
yes just to say the investment plan is
very strongly focused on getting money
out into our parishes
and where it will choose the most for
the residents and it'll be a key way to
support our local communities so very
much looking forward to seeing it work
for them and propose recommendations in
the report
yeah just very briefly i mean i think
this has been done to a very tight time
frame but it's not being done in the
next um we have consulted widely so lots
of people have had an opportunity to uh
to comment on it
i think uh the eleven themes um are
brilliantly covered
and i think that um
it will have very wide benefits right
across the district
and in terms of our different
communities whether that be our
residents
or uh or uh
businesses which would be
london thank you
thanks very much that's been proposing
second then
any other comments
no okay
okay
thank you
the last item is items um
so thanks everyone for joining us
see you next time